being a character actor is a pretty
sweet deal while they may not earn the
fame fortune or accolades afforded a
list movie stars some do get to live
their dream and become very
well-regarded for their work and there
are other perks to the gig like landing
in a delightful crowd-pleasing gag reel
here are some performers who at the end
of the day are probably best love for
their bloopers
Christopher dargah and Bruce Almighty
Jim Carrey improvises so much on set
that directors are left with a wealth of
extra hilarious and often unusable
footage this means that any day player
who had a scene with Carrey could also
wind up in the gag reel that's what
happened to Christopher dargah who
played a baker in Bruce Almighty it must
be wonderful seeing the smiles on their
little faces
I would have come back I see those funds
d'argo was forever immortalized in film
history as a guy who can't keep a
straight face forever
[Music]
do cut kin for a and Halloween horror
movies can provide a cathartic
psychological release but you have to
laugh a little at this tragic fate and
when actor Kim for a did just that he
provided perhaps his most famous screen
work I got a taco the Love Supreme
talking back at me so I'ma be a while
while filming his character's violent
end for 2007 s remake of Halloween for a
can't help but find a stabbing rather
humorous
[Music]
some kid in North by Northwest one of
the most memorable outtakes from classic
cinema comes from Alfred Hitchcock's
1959 classic North by Northwest it
includes one of Cary Grant's best
performances now I have that effect on
people isn't something about my face
it's a nice face but the actor who
really made history is an anonymous
child extra grants co-star Eva Marie
Saint is about to fire a gun in a
crowded cafeteria which we know from the
kid in the background who plugs his ears
in anticipation Paul Freeman in Raiders
of the Lost Ark character actor Paul
Freeman appeared in one of the most
acclaimed and highest-grossing
blockbusters of all time she had taste
in friends remains consistent but
Freeman would become most famous for his
role as bellick in 1981 s Raiders of the
Lost Ark because of a fly that crawled
into his mouth the persistence surprises
even me given a good listener is a bad
name soupy sales in the Soupy Sales show
unlike other iconic Kitty TV show hosts
like Captain Kangaroo or mr. Rogers
Soupy Sales didn't run a cuddly
educational show lunch with Soupy Sales
aka the Soupy Sales show was pure comedy
for example he took a pie to the face
most every day and he used a stage door
from where all manner of crazy guests
would emerge perhaps because the show
was light and ephemeral or perhaps
because it wasn't rerun for decades
sales is probably best remembered for a
stage door prank where a topless dancer
greets him by surprise
a gag which obviously never hit the air
[Music]
Stanley Anderson in spider-man probably
thanks to an extensive theatrical
background stanley anderson projects a
lot of gravitas and hubris which
certainly helped him win the role of
General Slocum and intimidating military
official who could handle bossing around
Willem Dafoe in 2002 spider-man but
Anderson just couldn't get through the
word predecessor which means he'll live
on forever in the gag reel
I never supported your program we have
my predecessor to your mother I give all
right Brian steel in Blade Trinity even
the biggest fan of Wesley Snipes vampire
hunting trilogy probably wouldn't
recognize Brian steel in Blade Trinity
he played the mighty Dracula which
required layers of prosthetics and
makeup steel was supposed to play his
character's death as an extremely
violent one but ended up laughing his
way through the outtakes Rachel Dratch
as debbie downer
a remarkably talented comedian and
actress Rachel Dratch is best known for
her seven year stint on Saturday Night
Live she performed several recurring
characters but the piece for which
stretch will forever be remembered is a
Debbie Downer sketch that went
completely off the rails while
portraying a family eating breakfast at
Disney World
almost the entire cast cracked up til
Schweiger in inglorious basterds while
german writer director and actor til
Schweiger is quite well known in europe
his most memorable american screen
appearance was as sergeant Stieglitz in
2009's inglorious basterds arguably
veigar's best moment is when he rises
from the dead to say hello to Sally
minky the film's editor and only person
who would see him come back to life
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]
you